the contentious Supreme Court hearing
featuring Christine Blasi Ford
overwhelmed the national sexual assault
hotline it fielded more than 3,000 calls
Friday that is a seven hundred and
thirty eight percent increase it was the
busiest day in the hotlines history more
than 25,000 people called in September
alone survivors are not only seeking
help they're also speaking with the
collective fury that's rarely been seen
before this may have been a turning
point for Senator Jeff Flake the moment
two sexual assault survivors cornered
him in an elevator Friday hours later
the Arizona Republican broke ranks and
called for an FBI investigation into
sexual assault allegations against
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
challenging victims to blame their
attackers directly White House counselor
Killian Conway revealed Sunday she too
is a survivor
I feel very empathetic frankly for
victims of sexual assault and sexual
harassment and rape that I'm a victim of
sexual assault I don't expect judge
Kavanaugh or Jake Tapper or Jeff Flake
or anybody to be held responsible for
that since dr. Christine Blasi Ford's
Senate testimony Thursday a record
number of callers have flooded the
national sexual assault hotline it's
calm enough whenever there's a there's a
sexual assault story in the news that we
see an increase in calls to the hotline
but nothing on the scale and we've we've
heard from so many callers that there's
something about having watched dr. Ford
that they identified with well you don't
respect her if you don't try to figure
out what actually happened miss Ford was
sympathetic and she was sincere on Face
the Nation John Dickerson spoke with
senators on both sides noted the change
in culture it is now the default in
America that accusers must be treated
seriously and respectfully now only the
willfully ignorant don't know why women
don't report abuse